hola cómo estás de nuevo en esta ocasión
voy a trabajar con el problema número 18
que es el último problema de esta
sección así que pues manos en la obra
problema número 18 y me dan una ecuación
me dan la siguiente ecuación h que
depende de t h que depende de ti es
exactamente igual hace menos menos de
menos 4 t cuadrada menos 4 t cuadrada o
no espera de hecho es menos 4 t
todo esto elevado al cuadrado ok y qué
me dice el problema siguiente me dice en
el tiempo igual a 0 una pelota fue
arrojada hacia arriba con una altura
inicial de 6 pies y eso es importante
dice antes de que la pelota toque el
suelo la altura de la pelota según un
tiempo dado está dada por la ecuación
siguiente esta ecuación de aquí así que
vamos a apuntar el otro dato que nos dan
antes x
olvide dice estamos en el tiempo cero es
decir la altura en el tiempo cero esto
es exactamente igual a 6 pies esto es
igual a 6 pies ok ya tenemos un dato
después dice donde se ideas son
constantes positivas vamos a aprenderlo
por aquí
y de son mayores que 0 ok y después dice
si la pelota alcanza una altura máxima
una altura máxima de 106 pies a los dos
segundos y medio eso también es
importante la pelota alcanza una altura
máxima de 106 pies a los dos segundos y
medio es decir que h de 2.5 de dos
segundos y medio es lo mismo que 106
pies de luz qué altura tiene la pelota
después de transcurrido un segundo de
ser arrojada es decir esencialmente lo
que nos preguntan lo que quiero saber es
cuánto vale h de 1h de 1 es la pregunta
de este problema muy bien pues manos en
la obra
para determinar la altura que vamos a
alcanzar en el tiempo de un segundo
sería muy bueno saber cuánto vale cm y
cuánto vale d
así que para calcular c y b vamos a
utilizar estos dos datos que me dan este
y este índice h de 0 70 esto es igual a
bueno a sustituir al tiempo por 0 me
quedaría ser menos
de -4 esto multiplicado por 0 y esto
todo esto elevado a su vez al cuadrado
pero bueno 4 por 0 esto se va y me
quedaría que esto es lo mismo que este
menos de cuadrada y esto a su vez es
igual al dato que me dan que es 6 esto
es igual a 6 es decir ya sé que se menos
de cuadrada es igual a 6 aquí tengo una
ecuación que tal vez ocupe el ratito es
más le voy a poner el nombre de uno
esta es la ecuación número uno ok que
más podría utilizar vamos a utilizar
este otro dato que me dan y dice h h de
2.5 esto es igual a 106 pero vamos a
sustituir el valor de 2.5 aquí adentro y
me va a quedar que esto es lo mismo que
ese menos
de -4 que a su vez multiplica a 2.5 que
a su vez multiplica a 2.5 todo esto
elevado al cuadrado y cuánto es esto
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que se menos
a ya que me queda de menos 4 por 2.5 es
lo mismo que 10 menos 10 todo esto
elevado al cuadrado y que podría ser
vamos a desarrollar este binomio
cuadrado perfecto para ver qué es lo que
me queda voy a obtener que a esto es lo
mismo que se menos y ya dentro de este
paréntesis que me va a quedar bueno pues
es el cuadrado del primero el cuadrado
del primero es de cuadrada de cuadrada
menos dos veces el primero por el
segundo este signo se conservan y dos
por de es 2 t por 10 es 20 de menos 20
de y después hay que sumarle el cuadrado
del segundo
bien todo esto debe de ser igual y aquí
voy a ocupar que esto es lo mismo que
106 esto es lo mismo que 106 este dato
me dan entonces esto va a ser igual a
106 ok voy a utilizar este dato para ver
qué ecuación encuentro de aquí primero
vamos a multiplicar por este signo de
menos y me queda que sean menos de
cuadrada más 20 de menos 100 esto es
igual a 106 ok de lujo porque ahora voy
a sumar 100 de ambos lados de esta
ecuación de tal manera que me va a
quedar que se menos de cuadrada
20 de esto es igual a 206 ok y ahora
bueno esta podría ser otra ecuación pero
pero qué crees aquí dice que ese menos
de cuadrada es igual a 6 c menos de
cuadrada es igual a 6 jajaja eso lo voy
a utilizar ser menos de 4 a da está
igual a 6 y aquí tengo c menos de
cuadrada pero sé menos de cuadrada vale
6 entonces esto es lo mismo que 66 y
déjame cambiar de ecuador a este juego
tenía no es este de aquí 6 más 20 de
esto es igual a 206 ok estoy utilizando
esta ecuación número uno esto es por la
ecuación número uno de lujo y entonces
aquí voy a restar seis de ambos lados de
esta ecuación y voy a obtener que 20 de
20 de es igual a 200 a 200 estos seis
aquí y seis acá este se va deprimen
quedan 200 o dicho otra manera
de lo voy a apuntar aquí de vale 200
entre 20 200 entre 20 este con este se
va y me queda 10 de vale 10 de lujo ya
tengo el valor de de ahora como puedo
encontrar el valor de ese pues voy a
utilizar esta ecuación la ecuación
número uno de aquí tengo que por acá le
voy a poner que sea menos de cuadrada
esto es igual a 6 pero de de ella
sabemos que vale 10 es más déjeme
atraparlo este dato es muy importante de
vale 10 ok del lujo entonces lo voy a
sustituir aquí y me va a quedar que sea
menos 10 elevado al cuadrado esto es
igual a 6 o dicho de otra manera se
menos 100 esto es igual a 6 o dicho de
otra manera se es igual a 106 aquí está
mi otra constante ya la hice se vale 106
de hecho es la altura máxima que alcanza
mi pelota en el tiempo de 2 segundos sin
medio se vale mi altura máxima y tiene
toda la lógica del mundo porque esta
función que tengo aquí es una parábola y
de hecho el pico de mi parábola el
vértice de mi parábola está en el valor
de este engine o dicho de otra manera el
valor máximo que toma esta parábola es
pues 106 tiene toda la lógica del mundo
además esta es una parábola que abre
hacia abajo ok por lo tanto el valor más
grande que se puede tomar es en 106 ya
tengo de ya tengo sé ahora qué te parece
sacamos h de 1 y para esto qué te parece
si me dejas bajar un poco la pantalla
para que así yo pueda poner la última
parte de la solución de este problema
déjeme bajar un poco la pantalla y lo
voy a poner aquí ha dicho espera déjame
ver qué función tenía en http es igual
hace menos este de aquí aunque hice
menos
- 4 t elevado al cuadrado ok entonces
ahora si bajemos la pantalla y bajemos
por acá la pantalla o algo así y voy a
poner que la función valía hd tm hd tm
era lo mismo que se menos un paréntesis
de menos 4 pm
todo esto elevado al cuadrado pero qué
creés ya sabemos el valor de d
ya sabemos el valor de s vamos a
sustituir lo htc hd tm es igual a cero
pero se vale 106 a 106 menos a abro
paréntesis y me va a quedar 10 10 - 4
portem todo esto elevado al cuadrado y
lo que me piden es hd 1 tengo justo aquí
entonces vamos a ponerlo la respuesta de
este problema es hd 1 y hd 1 lo podemos
obtener de la siguiente manera hd 1 es
igual a 106
a 106 - a 10 menos 4 porte pero en este
caso te vale 1 entonces por 1
todo esto elevado al cuadrado esto es lo
mismo que 106 menos a 10 menos 4 esto
elevado al cuadrado y esto es lo mismo
que 106 menos a 10 menos 46 elevado de
cuadrados 36 y esto es exactamente igual
a 106 menos 6 es 100 siendo unos 30 es
70 a 70 pies y esta es la solución del
problema
guau una solución bastante larga
encontramos la solución de este problema
con una ecuación original queda esta de
aquí después logramos encontrar cuánto
valía de cuánto valía cm y por último
calculamos cuánto vale
h de 1h de uno es exactamente lo mismo
que 70 pies ya está esta es la solución
de este problema 70 pies y bueno hemos
acabado esta sección así que nos vemos
en
el siguiente vídeo donde vamos a ver la
siguiente sección de este examen número
5 no dejes de vernos